hey guys new trailer for the seventh
season has finally been released and it
left me and most likely all of you
speechless this trailer couldn't be
better and it has also confirmed a few
major theories trailer starts with sense
of walking in the gods with the winter
foul while in the background we can hear
Littlefinger talking about fighting
battles then shot switches to the wall
and as I already said in my previous
videos gates are opening for bran and
Mira which this trailer confirmed then
he got to see a shot from the King's
Landing which will actually represent
urine coming to the capital and parading
with his prisoners all the way to the
red keep whereupon he will pledge his
army and iron fleet Cersei but this deal
will be accompanied with a marriage
between those two villains which is
confirming once again that Cersei and
urine will become allies there's all
sorry on horseback and is most likely
finally arrived at interval as well as a
few shots of the nearest at Dragonstone
where she will arrive in the very first
episode of the upcoming season while in
the background we can hear Jon Snow
telling to someone most likely to the
nearest as they will meet in Dragonstone
that their ancestors despite their
differences fought together for
centuries against their common enemy
with this speech Johnston will try to
persuade the nearest central forces to
the north to fight against the night
king and their forces instead of
battling Cersei in the urn while his
speech is accompanied in with this
beautiful shot of the nurses dragons
flying near Dragonstone however as you
can see in the trailer before Jon
convinces Dany to send her forces to the
north there will be a few major battles
between her forces and surface forces
the first fight will take place earlier
in the season and will be Daenerys is
ambushed and the Lannisters and the
tower lists will be heading home after
conquering Highgarden this battle that
was filmed for a few weeks will be the
biggest battle of the upcoming season
and will contain the nearest on drag on
leading the track accord in the first
battle in Seven Kingdoms which will
result the nurses victory with the death
of treason as head of house Tarly
Randall
while Jaime with bronze helpful somehow
managed to escape in the heat of the
battle and seek refuge at Casterly Rock
the second battle now between the
unsullied and the lancer forces will
take place a bit later upon Jaime's
escape to Casterly Rock who will not
stay there for too long
Daenerys will realize that the
Lannisters will not be defeated any time
soon if they have somewhere to run every
time they lose the battle
virtually denier so take the
through stronghold of house lannister
the incivility Casterly Rock and will
most likely conquer it there's also a
shot of their own fleet which does not
represent Theon and yards attack on
King's Landing but rather your own
Greyjoy arriving with his prisoners to
pledge his army to Cersei and finally
marry a queen there's also an
interesting shot of brainwashing and
beside the river tree and witnessing the
upcoming battle between Jon Snow and his
team against the night king and his army
this barrel between beyond vol and me
Jon Snow along with birth and Arion
torment as well as wig injury Jorah the
Hound Thoris and a few more men will get
ambushed has now been once again
confirmed but now for good Jon's nobly
the small team which will contain
already mentioned characters beyond wall
in order to capture white and prove to
the rest of Westeros that the real enemy
is real and is coming however do
intermission John and his team will be
noticed and will get ambushed by the
night King and his undead army the same
trailer has also confirmed that Daenerys
with her three dragons will come to
rescue which fire behind the undead army
confirms the nearest with her dragons
who managed to save John's whole team
except for Torres who will get killed in
the very beginning of the battle and
except for Jon Snow who will be left
alone surrounded by the White Walkers
and by the Horde of whites
however while Jon will get severely
wounded he will not die as his uncle
Benjen stark will appear in the last
moment to save the day benjin will send
wounded Jon off on his horse and will
die for his nephew those final shots of
the trailer are accompanied with Senses
epic speech saying when the snows fall
and the white winds blow the lone wolf
dies but the pack survives and